the final departure date for the u.s
from afghanistan might not be so final
after all
by the end of tuesday president joe
biden is expected to decide whether to
unilaterally extend the august 31st
deadline for the u.s to withdraw from
afghanistan
with just a week to go congressman adam
schiff left a classified meeting on the
afghan exit plan saying the odds of
getting everyone out are slim and
growing slimmer each day given the
logistical difficulties
of moving people to the airport
and the limited number of workarounds
it's hard for me to see that being fully
complete by the end of the month and i'm
certainly of the view that we
maintain a military presence as long as
it's necessary to get all u.s persons
out
and to meet our moral and ethical
obligation to our afghan partners
afghanistan's new taliban leaders say
extending that deadline is a red line
the u.s crosses at its own peril then
president donald trump negotiated the
deadline with the taliban in exchange
for a promise that u.s troops would not
be attacked until then
we are well aware uh of
of uh of the stated desire
to
by the taliban to have this mission
completed by the 31st of august i would
tell you that we too
are still planning on completing it by
the 31st of august that is the mission
that would have been signed by the
commander-in-chief assigned to us and
that's what we're trying to execute
some white house advisors are reportedly
advising biden not to change the
timeline fearing an end to the ceasefire
pact with a taliban since the taliban
seized control in kabul on august 15th
the u.s has evacuated 37 thousand u.s
citizens allies and afghan special
immigrant visa holders the white house
says it will leave no american behind
we believe
that we have time between now and the
31st to get out any american who wants
to get out even allies question whether
the u.s can finish the job by the end of
the month
at a virtual meeting of g7 leaders on
tuesday biden will have to answer to
critical state leaders demanding to know
if everyone who needs to be evacuated
can really get out by next tuesday
if that deadline doesn't change in kabul
and in the capitals of anxious allies
around the globe time is quickly running
out john hendren al jazeera washington